foreign
[Applause]
garments have eroded The credibility of
democratic institutions
what's at stake is democracy
we have a president that is constantly
telling his supporters that they should
shoot their positions today
[Applause]
[Music]
technology
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
stems no
no
America
[Music]
we have 33 million people in hunger
state in Brazil in a country that feeds
one billion people in the world
[Music]
life just seems to get worse and worse
if we look back to all the presidential
candidates that we've had in the past
the only two that created movements
around their personas were Lula and
bolsonar that is why we have lulismo and
that is why we have all sonarism
[Music]
thank you
Brazil is as divided as it is fast
Latin America's largest nation is about
to face the most consequential election
in decades with the country Torn Between
Two charismatic but controversial
personalities
on one side is incumbent right-wing
president jair bolsonaro on the other
veteran Social Democrat and former
leader Luis inacio Lula da Silva
we are going to take you on a journey to
meet Farmers evangelicals the
poverty-stricken and the elite to see
how Brazil its economy and culture are
evolving and see where the country could
go under a new leader
the winner will navigate enormous
economic and social challenges while
facing a polarized Nation
he will govern not just one Brazil but
the multiple brazils that inhabit the
Region's most populous country
foreign
despite strong growth forecasts for this
year the quality of life for many
Brazilians has declined inflation this
year soared above 10 percent
and battered by two recessions the
economy grew just 0.15 percent on
average annually between 2012 and last
year
but in some parts of the nation the
picture is a lot brighter our journey
starts in the booming agricultural state
of goyas we've come to meet Fernando
Jose is
God
the 32 year old farmer trained as a
lawyer at one of the country's Elite
universities
when his father died he moved back to
run the family business
he now owns a 5 000 Acre Farm with 7 000
cattle and vast vegetable plots
out here this is a medium-sized Farm
positive
[Music]
for centuries Brazil was a coastal
Nation the cities and states of Rio De
Janeiro and San Paulo dominated while
it's vast Dusty interior was disregarded
even derided
that is changing the states in the
country's Heartland are now booming this
is the Brazil of Agriculture which feeds
a growing chunk of the world's
population
after the Russian Ukraine conflict
erupted that we noticed how important
Brazil became as a food producer for the
World perhaps the most important food
producer in the world
in the last decade agribusiness has
grown to now represent as much as 27
percent of GDP
what once was scrubland has now been
transformed
known as the sahado the vast tropical
Savannah region is Rich in biodiversity
and a crucial carbon sink for the world
but it's been radically changed in the
past 50 years
[Music]
soils have been turned to some of the
most productive in the world yet Rising
clearances for crops and livestock have
alarmed ecologists
for Outsiders the Brazilian president is
often viewed as vulgar and authoritarian
but here in Brazil's Bread Basket
bolsonaro is an icon
Federal lawmakers representing
agricultural regions are among the
president's closest allies the
difference between bolsonaro and the
other candidates is that he not only
tapped into that audience and that group
of Voters in a politically political way
bringing the caucus to his political
Alliance he tapped it in a cultural way
in a traditional way in a in a social
way in a behavioral way
over a hearty meal of barbecued Meats
Fernando explains the importance and
development of the local culture
I don't know
certain Asia is Brazil's version of
country music
check shirts cowboy boots and songs
about heartache and suffering
this is the essence of the farming
community
Olson arrow is often seen at events
celebrating the local Cowboy culture the
economic and cultural Revival of
Brazil's agri-states has also spurred a
construction boom the state capital of
koyanya a sprawling city of 1.5 million
has doubled in size in the past 40 years
we're here to meet delegado valdir a
former police chief now running for the
Senate once a kiali of bolsonaro he's
distanced himself from the gath prone
president
says the government is doing some things
right
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign States like goyas are one of the
reasons why Brazil remains an attractive
investment destination
foreign direct investment Rose to almost
40 billion dollars in the first five
months of this year the largest inflow
in this period since 2011.
delegado valder believes productivity is
the answer is
but support for bolsonaro is not limited
to the agri-business bubble
many Brazilians share his conservative
values and Echo his faith in God and
family
some share his outspoken views on gay
rights
this is the Brazil of Evangelical
Christianity a religion exploding in
popularity and in political influence
the data is clear evangelicals are set
to overtake Catholics by the end of this
decade
[Music]
while bolsonaro is officially a Catholic
he regularly makes overtures to the
Evangelical churches
in 2016 he was re-baptized by an
Evangelical pastor
his wife is a well-known Evangelical
winning this community's vote has been a
key play for bolsonaro we can't deny
that Brazil has a conservative way of
seeing uh life we are a country for
instance where more than half of the
population is against abortion more than
half of the population is against
legalizing drugs we have a growing
population of evangelicals in the
country 10 15 years ago this was at
around 18 20 percent today it's around
30 32 percent
and we never had a conservative
politician being able to organize this
uh this Arena of thoughts bolsonaro did
We've Come to an Evangelical Church and
a smart new neighborhood in goyanya
inside a mostly young white congregation
is transfixed by the service
[Music]
on the stage is hinaldo Silva the 28
year old leader of the church known as
impactados the impacted
they call him the bishop
um
no
[Music]
stems
Mass internally a ruler is
the
presidential
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
he's seeking re-election and the
pastor's endorsement could make a
difference
your time's close relationship between
religion and politics has helped Propel
all kinds of politicians to power
the fear of what a Lula Administration
may bring is echoed by the nation's
powerful Truckers
it's not an easy job being a truck
driver in Brazil says Wagner fialio had
a stop on the outskirts of godania
is
[Music]
they said foreign
[Music]
[Music]
turkey
foreign
intense it is not foreign
served two terms as president between
2003 and 2010 but was later embroiled in
the lavajato OR Car Wash corruption
Scandal and served time in prison
his convictions were later annulled by
the Supreme Court while separate
criminal cases were either shelved or
expired due to time limits legal history
aside Lula has managed to connect with
millions of Voters as they seek a change
from the chaotic bolsonaro years
the left-wing former labor organizer has
a strong following in the country's
poorest regions and in many of its large
coastal cities
despite unemployment falling to nine
percent in recent months many Brazilians
rely on the government to help make ends
meet
[Music]
Fabiana de Silva is a Lula supporter
living in one of Sao Paulo's poorest
neighborhoods
she lives in what is called an
occupation a type of shanty town more
precarious than the more well-known
favelas
Fabiano
[Music]
Fabiana
um
[Music]
maximum
[Music]
[Music]
for Fabiana and millions like her the
pandemic and Rising inflation have only
exacerbated the hardship
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
food insecurity has increased and
millions have been plunged into hunger
30 of the population are now living on
less than 95 dollars per month
10 million more Brazilians have fallen
into poverty since the pandemic
is
[Music]
thank you
foreign
Orlando Silva is an influential lawmaker
and close Ally of Lula
speak with him at a campaign event in a
Recycling yard in a working-class
neighborhood of Sao Paulo
um
foreign
foreign
the racial divide in Brazil is Rio and
and you don't need data to to to confirm
that all you need is to walk around the
big cities to take a look in Congress
and to take a look at big companies to
take a look in uh wealthier areas of the
city and poorer areas of the city to
look at the numbers of incarcerated
population uh for instance
um and and this is a problem of also
representativity we don't have uh in
Brazil when you look at the Brazilian
Congress at the elected officials
not even close to a presence of what you
would expect looking at the demographics
of the country of the black population
of women but I think that this is
something that the country has to
address
one way or the other
some things are slowly changing
is one of the country's most prominent
center-left politicians
raised in a favela in Sao Paulo's South
zone are Savvy use of social media and
Progressive agenda have prompted some to
dub her Brazil's answer to Alexandra
ocasio-cortez
she thinks the country is facing a
critical moment I would say this is
probably the hardest moment my country
has faced since democratization so for
the last 30 for 40 years
the first thing that comes to my mind is
hunger right now the last number we have
we had access to shows us that 30
million Brazilians are not having their
meals this means that 15 of our
population
is not getting the basic it's not
getting what they need with bolsonaro
and the pandemic I saw people very close
to me not having anything to eat and I'm
talking about a knot I'm talking about
the mother of a friend and I saw many
people
being put off their their homes I saw
many people become unemployed and we are
in this moment that life just seems to
get worse and worse
she thinks that bolsonaro's aggressive
and misogynistic rhetoric is inflaming
things
already the election has been married by
sporadic violence and she fears for her
personal safety we have a president that
is constantly telling his supporters
that they should shoot their position
and that's a very strong message and
that especially scary to me because in
those four years I had to learn with my
team how to deal with threats that I
received at home that I received through
email in the social media and when I'm I
was organizing things for the campaign
of this year talking about our personal
security was always a main issue fears
about security have dominated headlines
with bolsonaro regularly casting doubt
on the electoral process
this uncertainty has rattled many even
the country's Elite
Felipe Davila is one
a Scion of a political family who
married the daughter of one of the
nation's richest men Davila is now
running for the presidency and polling
in low single digits
he says years of populist governments
under both Lula and bolsonaro have left
Brazil in a precarious position we're
living in one of the most dire moments
of Brazil right now I think it's the
greatest challenge we do have in our
democracy since 1985.
and this is due to many years of
populist governments populist
governments have eroded The credibility
of democratic institutions
they have eroded the ability of Brazil
to grow in a sustainable way
populism has destroyed the credibility
of democracy has widened the gap of
income in Brazil and for the first time
we're already a country back with hunger
and this is extraordinary you'll have 33
million people in hunger state in Brazil
in a country that feeds one billion
people in the world due to its good
agriculture this is tragic and the
economy doesn't grow so we have not been
able to achieve
consensus in society
to approve major stricter reforms to
create equality of opportunity in Brazil
specifically in education in health in
sanitation and of course economic growth
so I think this election since we have
two populist leaders leading the
campaign at this moment
this could put a tremendous burden in
democracy in Brazil in the next four or
five years
and that's very sad
Brazil is in for a bumpy ride
political polarization has morphed into
cultural polarization the coast and the
interior are increasingly divided
exacerbating this is the widening
economic chasm
while the interior talks of progress and
development the coast must deal with
poverty and deep inequality although
agribusiness entrepreneurs such as
Fernando continue to prosper there are
still millions of Brazilians in
situations similar to fabianas
for them not even the basic necessities
of life are a given
whoever wins the polls will have to
navigate many competing often
conflicting interests
the next president will have to Captain
not just one but multiple brazils
[Music]